Decided it's going as I've gotten older,
I can't even read my Twitter feed.
I have,
fuck these people.
I don't live,
I don't read it.
If I don't put my glasses on,
I don't know what the fuck they're saying.
Oh my God,
it's so,
so,
so good.
But get depressing.
It actually,
I'm sitting psychosis is a different thing.
Okay.
I think we're,
we're,
we are dope though.
Discussing overall mental health.
Yes.
I mean,
look,
I'm saying this because I really think that this is something that I've,
I've made a big turn over the last few years,
uh,
with myself that I take a quick bathroom break.
He's gone.
I don't think marijuana is a safe,
as I used to think it is.
I used to think it was benign.
I really used to think there was no big deal.
But I have a friend that I discussed the other day who was a really confident
fucking muscular,
handsome man that never did anything.
And he took a marijuana edible to go to sleep.
And for two weeks,
this guy was funny.
This is a different guy.
Not that I was talking to.
Not Not Rafi,
no.
A different guy.
He took it and the experience,
suicidal thoughts and all these,
he had like severe consequences.
I think that the human beings,
we vary so much biologically that to just make this overall blanket statement,
what's good for you is good for me is irresponsible and I've been irresponsible
in saying that.
Well one reason,
it's interesting,
one not reason.
I think that alcohol is so widely accepted despite all the problems it causes.
And again,
alcohol can certainly cause problems is that alcohol affects most people pretty
much the same way.
You know if,
and you sorta know if what somebody looks like when they have one drink,
when they have five drinks,
I've got some trans,
I've got some friends that get those [inaudible] you ever see when people get
sharp guys they just gone.
Then they start talking crazy and like Whoa,
but you sorta know that and you sort of know how long it's gonna take to clear
your body.
Yes,
cannabis is so different.
It's really complicated drug and it does affect different people in different
ways.
And also the tolerance has changed radically.
So you know,
people say,
well two and a half milligrams of Thc,
you vape it.
That's like one drink for somebody who you know,
who doesn't use.
But then if you're,
if you're a tolerant user,
you can use 200 milligrams in a day.
That's 80 drinks.
It's a weird drug.
And then there's the issue of eating it.
When you eat it,
your body produces something called 11 hydroxy metabolite.
It's a far more psychoactive.
You were all along for the ride when that happens.
Yes you are.
Yes.
And it can take days for it to get out of your system.
I know many people have eaten marijuana edibles and then they call me up the
next day like,
dude,
I'm still hot.
Yeah,
it's true.
So I think,
I think the legalization community has sorta said for years like,
oh,
there's basically no downsides to this.
There's only upsides.
The cops will bus smokers,
there'll be tax revenue.
All these people have a way to get high.
That's clearly safer than alcohol.
And unfortunately that's just not true.
I think you're right.
And I think the,
the issue that people,
from what I've read are having with your book are people that are marijuana
advocates to think that your position is unbalanced and that you've ignored the
positive aspects of THC in terms of like what he was talking about cognitive
benefits for people with psychotic episodes and that you are only focusing on
the negative or plead guilty to that cause I think that for 20 years people have
only heard the positive.
Right.
I think that's a,
I think that's also I'll plead guilty to up myself cause I think that I've only
been discussing the positives and one of the things that I've tried very hard to
do and one of the things I've learned how to do from doing this podcast and
experienced in criticism and communicating with a bunch of different people with
a lot of different viewpoints is examine my own positions and try to figure out
am I coming at this from a truly balanced position or am I trying to support a
conclusion that I started out with and I'm trying to,
you know,
somehow or another backup my own work or back up my own,
my own statements and,
and,
and sort of prop them up instead of being really honest and objective.
It's very difficult to do.
I wrote a book called Tell Your children the truth about marijuana,
mental illness and violence.
I don't think you can,
you can think that that book is going to be a compendium of the pros and cons of
both.
If you want to tell your children the truth though,
you really do want to tell them the pros and cons,
right?
And you did indicate,
Alex,
you said,
you know,
we should tell people the truth in the book,
right?
So you know,
I think that when you're telling it and you're saying that,
that you're telling the truth,
and Alex,
I'm agreeing with you that you're telling part of the truth,
right?
But part of the truth is,
you know,
a little bit deceiving and deceptive in some ways,
right?
You want to tell the whole truth when you tell the whole truth,
then you give the whole story and then people can actually make you know,
a good informed decision based upon that.
If people are going to just read one part of the story,
then of course they're going to make a decision just based upon that one part.
They're not going to make an informed decision based upon all of the parts.
And because of that,
people are going to make you know,
some very poor choices.
I completely agree with that.
But to me,
the last 20 years have been an exercise in the other side,
in the legalization side,
doing a very,
very good job talking up its arguments.
And essentially there's,
there's almost nobody on the other side.
There's this one guy can't see what's going on.
Jeff sessions,
he had the fucking Goddamn attorney general telling people that good people
don't smoke marijuana.
And that's literally a quote that says,
yeah,
thank God that little more on,
it's not in an office anymore.
But that's,
that's a terrible thing to say.
People don't smoke marijuana.
I,
there's a lot of wonderful people who smoke marijuana.
That's just not true.
And by the way,
I think this is a personal choice.
Okay.
Especially for adults and,
and you can make bad personal choices.
You Go,
look,
I play cards.
I love to play poker.
I'm sad that on this trip to La,
I didn't get to go to a poker room.
But you can go into casino and you can see people who've lost change your flight
places close by him already.
He used to make a living doing that.
When I'm struggling with comedy,
don't encourage me.
Um,
but,
but you can go to a casino and see people who've lost their houses.
It doesn't mean that gambling should be illegal.
It also means that there's less and more dangerous forms.
That device in your hand where you can bet on what the next pitch is going to
be.
If it's going to be a baller circle,
that's more dangerous than my having to drive to the commerce and play there.
And 100% or 98% THC that an 18 year old vapes is a lot more dangerous than a 5%,
you know,
CBD 15% THC product.
The doctor heart might suggest is patient uses once a night to go to sleep.
But that,
but that's the message that,
you know,
we should be putting out there,
right?
We shouldn't just be focusing on one side of the story.
Like that part,
you know,
should also be included in the book and like,
you're a book.
Um,
you know,
in some ways has made me rethink the way that I write.
You know,
because my first book was coauthor with Jeremy Costs and called friendly fire.
my second book that I'm writing now is called cannabis for PTG.
So is how to transform posttraumatic stress into posttraumatic growth,
right?
Because I feel that,
and you know,
we all know examples of people that have you encountered really difficult
obstacles in their life and some people have,
you know,
succumb to that stress and they've gone down the wrong path kind of thing.
And then other people have used that stress to their advantage and they've
actually become better because of it.
And you know,
um,
CBD and Thc can both help facilitate that process.
You know,
when you're looking at someone like a veteran,
for example,
you're the hallmark of song with his PTSD is someone who doesn't leave their
home and they can't sleep at night.
So like when I see that in my office,
a lot of the times they'll be leaving their home like five to 10 days a month,
right?
So when you give him CBD,
and this is really important for people to understand,
CBD has been shown to decrease learned fear.
That's incredible,
right?
So,
um,
if you can get people outside of their home,
because I'm not talking about,
again,
you know,
someone who's,
I'm too nervous to like go to,
uh,
you know,
the bar with like the friends and stuff like that.
I'm talking to people who were like,
you know,
it was difficult for them to go to the grocery store,
just like pick up a few things.
So,
you know,
those are the type of people that I see in my practice of CVD is really
excellent for that.
Then when you look at,
you know,
the,
the nighttime component,
um,
you know,
THC,
again,
it's excellent for reducing nightmares.
That's been shown in studies and it was even shown with one pharmaceutical drug
nabilone.
Again,
I don't really use nabilone very much because it's only one cannabinoid and I do
believe in,
in,
in the entourage effect and using all of the cannabinoids.
So I don't use that that much,
but that shows that she,
she came reduce nightmares and you know,
if you have,
you have,
if you have PTSD,
I mean if you talk to someone who has PTSD,
and again this is,
this comes from a clinician's point of view,
they will tell you,
I will try anything.
And that's the same way when you get with like,
you know,
um,
the parents of,
of,
of a,
of kids who have seizures all day,
nobody wants to see that you like and like,
and like Alex,
you know,
if your kids,
ever started getting,
getting seizures,
which,
you know,
I hope,
I hope they don't because it's,
it's terrible.
You know,
what,
what it can do to people.
But if that ever happened,
you know,
I would hope that you would consider,
CBD as a potential treatment option.
He's not against that.
I think we have to be really clear as a distinction.
Like CBD,
you're not against.
You would be at all.
And I don't,
I don't think anybody is.
I think no one really is arguing except maybe the federal government in certain
levels is arguing against CBD.
That's probably some pushback from the pharmaceutical industry.
The reality is CBD is proven to be,
at least as far as I've read,
very safe and very effective for a bunch of different disorders,
especially those that are about reducing.
And I have something to do with inflammation or seizures.
Yeah.
One of my good friends,
his son has,
uh,
developed seizures and CBD knocked it out,
just killed it,
killed it.
This is very recently,
you're somebody who's a,
you know,
who's a cannabis user.
You obviously know a lot of users.
Why do you think it is that people,
you know,
in legal states where they can really express a preference,
they can go into a dispensary,
know exactly what they're buying.
Why is it that they want such high potency THC product?
Because they get used to it?
Um,
you,
your tolerance develops,
it builds up.
You know,
every year we do this thing called sober October.
Well,
we don't do any,
no drinking,
no,
no pot.
And we do do some sort of crazy challenge.
Uh,
me and three of my buddies and,
uh,
when we do it,
what,
what's,
it's very interesting how your tolerance is radically reduced.
Like I'll smoke pot at the end of that month and I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Like I don't even know what I'm talking about in the mid sentence and I'm just
blitzkrieg whereas,
you know,
now like,
uh,
I smoked a little weed last night,
did some stand up,
had a great old time.
There was no,
no issues with it at all.
But I'm used to it.
And if the weed that I smoked last,
I,
I assume you don't smoke.
I do not.
Okay.
If you and me were together last night and I gave you a hit of my joint,
you'd beat still there in the corner,
in the fetal position going,
what in the fuck is going on?
Because the marijuana is ridiculously powerful.
But once you're accustomed to it,
once your body acclimates,
it's really not that big of a deal.
The problem is,
uh,
you,
you're dealing with a lot of habitual daily users.
And for those people,
like my friend Joey Diaz,
there's a video of him giving this a other comedian,
uh,
w how many milligrams of those stars of death,
Tilly when we give Owen,
what did he give?
Oh,
I think just one.
He ruined his life would have been about 200 to 250,
two 50 door and went out.
The Joey made a video,
but the day changed Owen's life.
Like literally fucked the guy's head up.
Like he went outside and he vanished and he's gone.
That's cannabis.
Like,
oh,
well I think,
I think there's a real argument to be made.
It's particularly with him.
It was going to make two points on that.
So you definitely came develop a tolerance and I tell people all the time,
try and take at least one,
three week break.
Um,
but the evidence does show that,
uh,
if you stop for four weeks,
generally all your receptors return and it'll be like you've never used cannabis
before.
She saw it.
And that's even with people who are really,
really heavy users,
I can go back and get the study.
Um,
but I mean these people are you using,
I'm pretty sure it was like close like seven joints a day.
Well,
really heavy users and snoop Dogg's a good example of that.
And my friend Tony Hinchcliffe was good buddies with snoop Dogg and he said
snoop dog just smokes all day.
And he'd just like,
he's always high and you know,
they're like,
well what do you do when you're not high?
He's like,
what?
I'm never not high.
So everything he does,
he has high as fuck everything he does.
Like for that guy,
it's not that big of a deal.
And for the way he lives his life,
like he's just a relaxed,
easy going guy.
It's no problem.
You can be high all day and live his life and he's obviously wildly successful
with this strategy.
Yeah,
wildly successful.
And the second point I was gonna I was gonna make on that too though,
was there does not appear to be any tolerance at the CB two receptor.
So cheesy attaches to the CB one receptor.
And that's,
and that's where we know we can get tolerance.
You know,
some people,
you know,
they have some pain that use some cheap cheapsy and sometimes they need a little
bit more,
sometimes asleep,
you know,
the youth QC,
it'll work and then we'll stop working with CBD to,
we haven't seen that.
Meaning like the people who,
uh,
you know,
get,
get seizure control generally they don't need to increase the dose.
Like the girl I was talking about earlier,
um,
you know,
at first described,
I think when she was 20,
when she was buying him 20,
she's 25 now.
Um,
she's never increased her dose.
I mean,
she's just used the same amount to CBD for the last five years.
Medicine.
Right.
Like it works for you.
I think we should really stop talking about CBD.
I just didn't want to make a note on the,
uh,
on the tolerance of the CPU on,
I just wanted to make a note that CB two there doesn't appear to be tolerance.
And so it's just,
there's just such a significant impact,
um,
when it,
when it comes to especially edible THC,
uh,
it's a,
there's a significant impact on people's state of mind.
And it's not always good.
It's just a fact.